can you drop your alien footage
it's not that good Andrew have you seen
it yeah I've seen my have you seen your
alien food
wait it's not that good do you not know
about this no I do but how do you know
about this because I saw the clip I saw
him talk about it James Fox right yeah
but you never actually dropped the clip
no I need I need someone to come out and
be like this is what this technology is
and then if it's matched up with what I
have I'll be like I also have something
to corroborate that can I ask you it
sounds like you're doing some Dylan [__]
right now are you talking about it it
just sounds like you have something that
doesn't exist I've capped about one
thing on this entire podcast what what
[__] a dude wait the version you
never said you [__] a guy
yeah
I thought I made a joke
about did you go legs up or did you come
on
yo come on bro come on that was what his
[__] looked like
give us the before
first time I ever hung out with Rogan it
was dinner with him and Bobby was there
yeah
do you believe him I believe he believes
it that's a whole other thing though
because because that's a thing called
delusion and a lot of people on this
planet suffer from that yeah I believe
he believes it damn
like how can you how can you even begin
to craft that type of story I I don't
think a story is crafted I think that he
was reverse engineering technology that
he thought was alien and maybe we've
created that kind of Technology maybe
it's Chinese yep please talk about
anti-gravity do the Chinese drink Pride
uh it's not available in China yet oh
how would they pronounce it okay guys
this show has been brought to you
[Laughter]
um doing comedy in Manchester dude
you know this right yeah literally the
night after yeah you guys are fighting
I'm there and I'm we're there at yours
yeah [__] yeah how crazy in Manchester
how crazy is this that's where I just
came from by the way yeah I know we
signed earling [__] Holland as a
prime athlete that's crazy can we I want
to get back to all the prime stuff
because the prime stuff to me is like is
fascinating from also just a financial
perspective like how you guys are
whatever we get into this but I just
want to put a little button on the UFO
things
I think Lazar believes it I believe that
you believe that it's out there that
these Landings are real
I have one problem I also have theories
it's hard for me
to comprehend that a hyper Advanced
civilization or technology could travel
trillions of light years or miles across
the Galaxy you know hundreds hundreds of
millions thousands of light years across
the Galaxy and then crash at the last
like 50 miles on planet [__] Earth
that's crazy that's crazy why do they
have to crash
they don't have to crash I mean maybe
they ran out of alien gas
you know what you know what you know
what you know I think it could be oh you
did a whole pyramid thing you did it oh
you're into this [__] you had the
pyramid guy on yeah we have a couple Ben
van Kirkwood oh oh I I didn't get into
it the new [__] is Antarctica no
Antarctica's going crazy
what go what's what's going on what's
going on besides penguins
penguins are they how they distract you
yeah you still believe the Penguins yeah
penguins not real there's no actual Bird
that's a penguin yeah a bird with wings
that can't fly yeah right yeah right
yeah right what do you think of a
[__] stupid yeah we're not buying
this penguin [__] what we are buying is
the what is the weapon that they say
they have there
microwave weapons microwave weapons
microwave weapons yeah
no this is real oh yeah there's a guy go
podcast hey what's he saying he's saying
that they have directed energy weapons
well they can cause earthquakes around
the world this is [__] cool 100 cares
bro who cares you don't want to know
what's going on yeah
the thing about everyone's like whoa
we've [__] UFOs are real why do we
only have shitty videos of them we never
can capture them on camera
do you know how fast these things move
uh if you're traveling at super fast
yeah super duper super duper if you're
traveling at light speed
I saw this video of uh if the ISS
International Space Station was orbiting
Earth at 10 000 feet what it would look
like went across the sky it's you can't
even [__] see anything those things
allegedly move faster than even that
it's you you'd never be able to capture
them on camera because it crossed in
like the blink of an eye so like what
about the Tic Tac that thing David
fraver's Tic-Tac yeah he saw that flying
right next to him but that was caught in
a radar a radar camera right they were
able to lock on and track it and I
thought he soared with his eyes he was
able to see but then it was moving it
was stationary for a moment then it was
moving fast basically by locating to a
different place what I'm saying is
besides like hyper Advanced as far as
human technology goes uh radar military
technology it's going to be hard for a
Layman to capture these machines on
their phone you know that's that's all
yeah it'd have to be cruising it's more
likely than you think that you wouldn't
capture it on camera yeah and imagine in
order to get here you have to be able to
travel close to the speed of light so if
you can travel closely and then Andrew
takes so [__] long to get from
another planet imagine that 100 light
years away you're traveling at the speed
of light that's 100 years you must have
gone through a wormhole been in space
time that's facts
oh God deportation figure it out you
know who's gonna figure it out oh god
with the mustache
hair on his face do we cut kind of like
a bowl in the back and your shoulders
figure it out bro I can figure out
aliens yeah I figured out space travel
actually already oh yeah yeah wait what
was your thing they copied my [__] what
was your theory on that I remember you
sail on sun rays
I remember when you said that okay huh
you sail on the waves that the sun
provides you can go the speed of light
the light race imma [__] [__] up bro
go uh
because there are is no matter in space
there's no molecules the sun rays are
essentially non-existent you need matter
for the sun to heat up that's why this
is
basically hold just down face his face
is cold because there's no matter
for the sunlight to heat this is a
YouTuber right but if you're gonna if
you're gonna ride on the waves of the
Sun not ride on them
whatever it is as long as it's going the
speed of the sun we will go slightly
slower than that
we can't forget bubbles are over here
I'm just saying that's your first
Engineers you know that these things are
coming out something to harness that
power boom I didn't prepare I didn't
prepare for this type of car okay that's
what I want that's what we want from you